so computer files done quite a bit on
recursion but so far we haven't talked
about the idea of tail recursion which
is a simple trick for making recursive
programs more efficient and really it's
something that every programmer should
know about so that's what we're going to
look at today tail recursion so as we
often do with these things we're going
to start off with a simple example and
the example that we're going to look at
is the factorial function so what the
factorial function does is it takes a
number like four and it's simply going
to multiply all the numbers from four
down to one so we'll do four times three
times two times one which hopefully
equals 24 and this is a classic example
of a function that you can define
recursively with two cases so we have a
simple base case which says the
factorial of 1 is going to be 1 because
if you multiply the numbers from 1 down
to 1 there's really nothing to do you
just simply return the number one
straight away and then we have a
recursive case which says if you have
any other positive number n what you're
going to do is you'll take the number n
and you multiply it by the factorial of
n minus 1 so it's recursive because
we're defining the factorial function in
terms of itself we're saying the
factorial of a number n like 4 is going
to be n times the factorial of its
predecessor so it's a recursive function
that's defined in terms of itself let's
make sure we all understand how this
function is actually operating with a
simple example and we'll find it's
actually very inefficient and this is
where tail recursion is going to come in
to help us to make this function more
efficient so let's look at a simple
example so we do factorial of 4 and we
simply go to our definition and that
tells us that factorial of 4 is going to
be 4 times the factorial of its
predecessor which is 3 and then we think
well what do we do now well we're simply
going to take the factorial of 3 and
we're going to expand that as well so we
copy down what we had before we've got
four times and then we've got factorial
of 3 and I'm going to use brackets here
to make the structure or the grouping
explicit because that's going to be
quite important so we're doing factorial
of 3 which is 3 times the factorial of
its predecessor which is 2 and then we
simply do the same again we unwind the
recursion one more time we copy down
everything we had before we have 4 times
3 and then we get in brackets 2 times
the factorial of 1 and now we finally
reach the point where the recursion is
going to stop we've got a factorial of 1
here and by definition that was just 1
and then finally now we can start to
actually perform the multiplications so
we'll do 2 times 1 so I'm not going to
skip any steps here and then we do the 3
times 2 to get 6 and then finally we do
the 4 times 6 to get 24 you can see by
kind of expanding the definition here
that we've been able to see that the
factorial of 4 is 24 using a simple
recursive definition but unfortunately
this definition is actually quite
inefficient and it's inefficient in
terms of the amount of memory it uses
and you can see this just by looking at
the structure of what I've written down
here we start off with factorial of 4
which is small and then we get a bigger
expression here and a bigger expression
here and a bigger expression here and
this is because we're unwinding the
recursion and we need to unwind or apply
all the recursion before we can actually
get to the point where we do any of the
multiplications and then we can do the
multiplications and things shrink down
again at the end and it's got kind of a
triangular shape you start off with a
small term at the top or a small
expression and as you go down the
expression is getting bigger and bigger
until you finally reach the end of the
recursion and then you can start doing
the multiplies and it all shrinks down
to the end so it's like a triangular
shape so this kind of shows us with the
simple example that this is potentially
inefficient in terms of how much memory
it uses and you can imagine for example
if you calculated the factorial of a
large number like a million you'd have
to build up this very large intermediate
expression counting down from a million
down to one building up all the
multiplications in the middle before you
actually get to the end and you can
start collapsing this whole thing down
so this function works it has the
correct behavior but it's not
satisfactory because it uses too
much memory so we can fix this using the
idea of what's called tail recursion so
what I'm going to show you now is how to
redefine this function in a way which
gives the same answer as before but is
actually much more efficient and we'll
see afterwards that this is what's
called tail recursion so I'm going to
redefine the factorial function and I'm
going to use a little helper function
which I'm going to call go and now this
is often the name that people use for
these things and go is going to take two
parameters or two inputs the first one
will be the number we're trying to
calculate the factorial of that's just N
and the second parameter is going to be
what's called an accumulator and this is
just a simple value that we're going to
use to build up a running multiplication
as we go along rather than waiting until
the end and then doing all the
multiplications backwards we'll do the
multiplications as we go along and we'll
use this extra argument to accumulate
all of those various forests so how does
the go function itself actually get
defined well there's two cases for this
just like we have two cases for the
factorial function so the first case
says if you're trying to calculate the
factorial of 1 then you don't return the
value 1 anymore you can just return your
accumulated volume and if you're trying
to calculate the factorial of some
number N and you've got an accumulated
value a what you're going to do is call
the go function you'll decreed for
example and then the trick here is that
you're going to take your accumulator
value and you're going to multiply it by
n so we've got a simple recursive
definition here very similar to the way
the factorial function works but we're
going to see that this actually gives us
a much more efficient definition so
let's look at the same example as before
we're going to look at factorial of 4
and see whether this is more efficient
or not and actually check whether it
gives us the same result as well so
we're going to call go and we'll have
four and then we'll have our initial
accumulator value being 1 and what do we
do well we just go to the definition and
it says we subtract 1 from the first
parameter and then we're going to
multiply the 1 by the 4 so if we work at
a detail
that's very simple we're just going to
get three and four now we just simply
repeat the process we say what is go of
three and four well we call the go
function again and we decrement the
first parameter and then we multiply the
two parameters so in this case we
multiply the three and the four so we
get twelve and then we go one more time
we go we decrement the first parameter
so we get one and then we multiply the
two in the twelve and we get 24 now
we're finally down at the base case so
we can stop and we simply give back the
result 24 what you see here is that you
get the same result as we had before
factorial of 4 is 24 but now it's much
more efficient in terms of memory and we
can see this simply by looking at the
structure of what we have here we have
go applied to four and one then go apply
it to three and four and so on and so on
so the term here or the expression that
we're manipulating is simply a function
applied to two inputs that just uses a
very tiny amount of memory we don't need
to use enormous amounts of memory to
build up a large intermediate expression
which then we collapse down at the end
we're just using constant amounts of
memory as we go along and this is
achieved because the go function is
what's called tail recursive let's have
a look at the definition of the go
function in particular let's look at the
right-hand side of the recursive case so
the right-hand side tells us how to
calculate go of n a and if we think
about how this is actually evaluated we
would first of all subtract 1 from n
then we would multiply a and n together
to give our new accumulator value and
then finally the last thing that we do
is do the recursion so this is the idea
of tail recursion when you make a single
recursive call and the very last thing
you do is make that recursive call so
there's nothing to do afterwards
actually this is what's making this
definition more efficient than our
previous one because we don't need to
remember anything after we make the
recursive call to the go function and
this is in contrast to our original
definition of the factorial function if
we look at this definition and we think
well how does this right-hand side here
in the
case get evaluated or what we would do
is we'd first of all subtract one from n
then we'd call the factorial function
and once that had returned we need to
remember that we still need to do the
multiply so it's not tail recursive
because the last thing that we do is not
applying the recursive definition after
the recursive call we still need to
remember to multiply by n and that's the
source of our inefficiency here so
that's one example of tail recursion let
me show you another example of tail
recursion and what we're going to look
at is what's called the Fibonacci
sequence which is a very famous sequence
of numbers in computer science and
mathematics
so the fibonacci sequence begins in a
very simple way we simply have 0 and 1
these are going to end up being the base
cases for our definition and then the
Fibonacci sequence proceeds by simply
adding together the two previous values
so you add the zero and one to give one
you have the one on the one to give two
yeah the one on the two to give three
and then hopefully I don't mess it up
and the sequence proceeds out to
infinity so this is the Fibonacci
sequence how do we define this as a
recursive definition and as a very
simple way to do this but the very
simple way is actually going to be very
inefficient but we can make it efficient
using tail recursion so let me show you
the inefficient way first of all so we
can define a function which is going to
take a number as an input and and then
it's going to give us back the nth
Fibonacci number starting from zero
because computer scientists always count
from zero so the base case for the
definition if you want the zeros
Fibonacci number that's the first thing
in the sequence that's zero if you want
the first Fibonacci number counting from
zero that's the second thing in the
sequence so that's going to be one and
then if you want the end Fibonacci
number you take the two preceding ones
and you add them together so fib of n is
fib of n minus 1 plus fib of n minus 2
so that's a nice simple recursive
definition but unfortunately it's
horrendously inefficient for example if
you tried just calculating Fibonacci of
50 even using quite a fast machine even
after a few minutes it won't have
terminated it's going to take an awfully
long time to do
that and there's a number of problems
with the definition it uses double
recursion here we're making two
recursive calls that potentially could
be a source of inefficiency we're also
not using tail recursion because once
the two recursive calls finished
we still need to remember that we need
to add the two resulting numbers
together and actually there's another
source of inefficiency here if you think
about it this is recomputing the same
Fibonacci numbers all of the time so
let's see how we can use the idea of
tail recursion to make this recursive
definition more efficient or actually
extremely efficient so let's rewrite it
we use the same kind of trick as we did
before so we're redefining the Fibonacci
function and it takes a number n and
we're going to call a helper function
called goal and it's going to take n as
its first parameter and this time it's
not going to take an accumulator as its
second input it's going to take a pair
of numbers
and the pair of numbers we're going to
take are simply the current Fibonacci
number and the next one so initially
we're going to have 0 and 1 because
those are the two first Fibonacci
numbers and then as we move along we're
going to kind of shift that little
window on the Fibonacci sequence along
so initially will be 0 1 then 1 1 1 2
and so on so I'm going to be shifting
that little window along so this is what
the go function is going to do for us so
there's three cases here so we could go
with zero we could go with 1 and we have
a pair a B or we could go with N and we
have a pair a B so we can think how do
we define the three cases so the two
base cases are very simple if I want the
0th Fibonacci number I've already got it
it's simply a if I want the first one
it's simply B and then if I want the
enth 1 all I'm going to do is call the
go function D chram entire so the for
would become 3 and then I take my little
window a B and I'm going to move it
along one so if a is the current
Fibonacci number and B is the next and I
want to move along one step then B will
now be the current Fibonacci number and
a plus B will be the next one so this is
the idea of just moving along a step so
a simple example with that would be if I
take the pair 2
three and move it along the three will
move into the first position and we are
the two numbers together and we get five
so that's kind of moving one step along
in the Fibonacci sequence so here is my
definition for the go function and
notice that it's tail-recursive it makes
a single recursive call and it's the
last thing that we do so in particular
and we think how does the right-hand
side here actually get executed well
we'd subtract one from n then we'd form
this pair B and a plus B and then the
very last thing we do is we make a
single recursive call okay there's no
more double recursion anymore so let's
just check that this actually works
correctly and that it is actually more
efficient so let's try calculating the
fourth Fibonacci number using this and
see what happens so we apply the go
function four is the first parameter and
we take zero and one as the current and
next Fibonacci numbers and then we just
unwind the recursive definition so the
four is going to D comment become three
and then we move our little window along
one so one is going to become the
current Fibonacci number and we add the
zero one to get the next one so we get
one one then we continue so we go we
decrement the three to get to the second
one becomes the first component of the
pair here and then we add the one and
the one to get two then we continue so
the two is now going to move over we're
shifting along one the tube becomes the
first thing we add the one in the term
we get three and then finally we reach
one of our base cases and that will be
the second component of the pair which
is three and we can just double-check
that that's correct and we go back to
the Fibonacci sequence and we're looking
for the fourth Fibonacci number counting
from zero so there's zero one two three
four so we find that three is the
correct answer here the point here is
that because the go function is tail
recursive we get this result extremely
efficiently if you look at the structure
of what we have over here it's very
simple we just simply have a function
applied to two numbers or three numbers
really four zero and one same here same
here and same here so we don't have a
computation or an expression which is
growing and shrinking it uses constant
memory here and it can run extremely
fast because of that
that's all for today that's just been a
quick introduction to the idea of tail
recursion and the idea is basically you
can sometimes make recursive functions
more efficient by making recursion the
last thing that you do and it's a simple
trick which really every programmer
should know something do you have to do
it manually or no that's a very good
question so I've shown how to do it
manually but actually there are systems
some compilers will do aspects of this
for you and there's various different
tricks that people can use is the tons
of research papers written about this
kind of stuff and there's some success
with this but it's not a kind of